madame marie annick duchêne pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
oui merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale la
multiplication d'incidents dans les
établissements scolaires l'évolution
préoccupante de ce phénomène et d'actes
qui relève pour moi plus du code pénal
que du simple fait divers devient une
vraie question de société
dans un contexte de banalisation de la
violence et de rejet de toute forme
d'autorité prévenir et lutter contre
cette violence en milieu scolaire est
une des conditions essentielles de la
refondation de l'école ce n'est que dans
un climat apaisé que tous les acteurs
pourront travailler en concertation dans
le respect des compétences dévolues à
chacun et dans un climat de confiance
mutuelle la refondation de l'école
monsieur mini ce n'est ces citera vous
le savez beaucoup plus que la réforme
des rythmes scolaires dans le rapport de
concertation je n'ai quasiment rien
trouvé sauf un peu page 45 qui
permettent de croire que vous vous
donnerez les moyens de relever ce défi
essentiel
rien qui laisse entrevoir des pistes
d'action pour faire reculer la violence
en milieu scolaire
monsieur le ministre
où sont les propositions et les
orientations du gouvernement pour
assurer la sécurisation des
établissements redonner du sens à la
prévention à l'éducation et aux
sanctions scolaires pour réintroduire
ifs enfin la fonction d'autorité
m merci monsieur vincent peillon
ministre indications nationale monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice vous avez
raison d'attirer l'attention de la
représentation nationale et du
gouvernement sur des phénomènes qui nous
touche tous
et dans le fond sont des blessures pour
notre république et en même temps pour
la transmission que nous voulons opérer
vers les plus jeunes
nous sommes évidemment les adultes car
j'entends souvent les discours sur la
jeunesse les premiers responsables de
cet état de fait et c'est ce qui a
justifié que le président de la
république ait décidé de faire de
l'école et de la jeunesse
la priorité non seulement parce que
c'est une catégorie mais parce que c'est
la france de demain et que nous voyons
bien dans la transmission d'un certain
nombre de valeurs dont l'ordre dont
l'autorité
nous avons ces dernières années failli
vous me dites et c'est à tort car je
crois pas que c'est un sujet de
polémiques en tous cas je ne le souhaite
pas la concertation n'a pas abordé ce
sujet la concertation étaient libres
d'aborder les sénateurs et sénatrices y
participer les sujets qu'elle voulait
mais le gouvernement aborde avec
beaucoup de résolutions
d'abord vous le savez sans doute nous
avons créé un nouveau métier c'était la
demande du président de la république ce
sont les assistants de prévention et de
sécurité
j'entendais une réflexion sur ces bancs
disant encore une commission non 500
emplois nouveaux qui sont déjà en train
d'exercer leurs responsabilités dans les
collèges les plus en difficulté
deuxièmement jamais jamais y compris
après dix ans vous étiez aux
responsabilités le terme violence
scolaire n'avait été inscrit
dans les directions de l'éducation
nationale j'ai demandé la création il y
à un mois et s'est fait d'une délégation
à la lutte à la prévention et à la lutte
contre les violences scolaires qu'ils
sachent charge et non seulement de nous
les faire connaître
mais de nous outiller pour lutter contre
cette violence et former les professeurs
à pouvoir réagir mieux en travaillant
d'ailleurs avec les services de justice
et avec les services de police
jamais je n'ai remis en cause vous
l'aurez noté y compris les équipes
mobiles de sécurité
le délégué qui a été nommé a été
auditionné par l'assemblée nationale
je vous conseille de faire la même chose
il a bien indiqué que dans les missions
qu'ils se confier c'était aussi que l'on
travaille mieux ces établissements
sensibles avec les équipes de sécurité
enfin je voudrais vous dire la chose
suivante chaque fois qu'un enseignant a
été agressé pour la première fois j'ai
utilisé l'article 40
il est inadmissible que des personnels
de service public ça vaut aussi pour les
élèves mais daumas responsabilité puisse
éprouver la moindre crainte a au nom de
nous tous transmettre les valeurs de la
connaissance et de la république
je souhaite que tous les français se
rassemblent autour de l'école tous les
français doivent se rassembler autour de
cet impératif
retrouvez l'autorité et je finirai en
vous disant la chose suivante nous avons
besoin d'adultes dans les établissements
nous avons besoin de recréer la
conscience nous avons besoin d'enseigner
la morale laïque
nous avons besoin aussi dans nos
comportements de faire preuve
d'exemplarité